no jaywalking on my watch he was tipping
off naughty baristas about undercover
investigations in return for sexual
favors the sheriff's sergeant from
sonoma's County Washington allegedly had
an understanding with scantily clad
ladies at several drive-through coffee
stands I protect you serve the officer
new employees at Java juggs and Twin
Peaks were under investigation for
allegedly flashing customers and turning
tricks and his insider tips helped them
stay one step ahead of the law I don't
know nothing about nothing I want to lay
low tonight a 30-year veteran is accused
of having sex with the owner and the
manager inside the stand while on duty
after his arrest sergeant Daryl O'Neil
was placed on paid administrative leave
the women suspected of prostitution
they were just arrested every once in a
while we have an officer that crosses
that line
maybe it's because so many other local
officers have dabbled an on-duty sex but
the local police and Sheriff's
Department seem determined to clean up
the area officers devoted many months to
staking out bikini baristas the
dedication deposed his customers and
pored over surveillance footage even the
FBI joined the investigation with
surveillance cameras of plenty but come
on don't cops and federal agents have
better things to do the swamis County
Sheriff's Department formed a special
task force devoted to catching violent
offenders and during the recent sweep
they spent three whole days catching bad
guys
maybe officers should spend even more
time catching violent criminals although
on the other hand that may mean fewer
bikini stakeouts sex presto
follow the show on Twitter submit your
nominees for next month and check out
Brad Hutchings this month's featured
follower the big shot with Twitter in me
are you twittering me
you